All across America, eccentric freedom lovers...
...have been protesting to reopen the country.
Now, beaches are the latest battleground,...
...and Florida's are open for business.
Northwest Florida beaches are back open.
Hundreds came out to soak up the sun, sand and surf.
I love the beaches being open.
This is just wonderful.
But while many Floridians are enjoying their God-given right to beach,...
...one of them has a killer protest of his own.
In northwest Florida, one lawyer took a bold approach to express his concern.
Thank you.
I'm here today to make a point that we need to...
I think it's premature that we opened our beaches.
But who was this strange Florida man?
Did terrorizing beachgoers actually make a difference?
To find out, I made a date with Death.
My name's Daniel Uhlfelder.
I'm a lawyer and I'm the Florida Grim Reaper.
So, what are you doing dressed as Death, going to the beaches in Florida?
We'll, we have a deadly virus that has killed over 75,000 people,...
...and I think people need to be staying home and taking precautions...
...and not flooding our beaches in our state.
Do you think you're making a difference?
The Grim Reaper is trying to preserve life.
As Death spoke unto me about the need for social distancing,...
...I realized that protesting to keep things closed could be helpful.
Even though Death is scaring the hell out of sunbathers,...
...at least he's wearing a mask.
Stay there.
Do not come to Death.